let's talk about the five top health tips of all
time someone suggested doing this on one of my
youtube videos so i sat down and really took a
look at what would be the most important tips
that you should focus on to do
that i had to first look at the top
worst tips of all time okay which are some
of these right here than to come up with
the best tips it's just a good way to figure
things out by looking at the opposite side
the problem that most people are running
into is that they're they google stuff and
they're trying to find the best tips but what
they're going to get is either the worst tips or
trivial things so what i want to focus on
is the most vital things to produce the most
health but mainstream talks about doing low fat
low salt drinking lots of water gallons of water
now there's nothing wrong with drinking enough
water but you could actually overdo it especially
if you're low on salt because you're diluting your
electrolytes if you're drinking gallons of water
now lean proteins people are brainwashed
to think that that's better than fattier
proteins but here's the thing lean proteins
will stimulate the hormone insulin okay which
by the way this is the number one tip most of you
already know this but for those of you that don't
keeping your insulin levels normal is probably the
best health advice you can give someone because
that's going to result in preventing so many
health problems from inflammation to a fatty liver
to metabolic syndrome to blood pressure to
decreasing your risk of getting cancer and
the list goes on and on and on to do that you
need to lower your carb consume fattier proteins
because leaner proteins on the insulin index
will stimulate insulin more than fattier proteins
and that also includes consuming an egg in
its whole form versus just the egg white now
vegetable oils as in soy oil corn oil canola
cotton seed are highly inflammatory and those
could actually trigger insulin resistance so when
you were taught that you had to replace saturated
fats with vegetable oils that is the worst advice
that you were given okay so we want to get rid of
the vegetable oils and use more saturated oils
coconut oil fat from butter things like that all
right next one is lose weight and get healthy now
if you look up pretty much any health condition
regardless of what it is like heart disease
whatever they're going to tell you you need
to lose weight you need to lose weight because
obesity is a risk factor well number three this
is better advice get healthy to lose weight
first okay not lose weight to get healthy
this right here might sound really kind of
simple and almost like idiotically obvious
but it's very very powerful because instead of
focusing on your weight you just focus on getting
healthy and guess what you will lose the weight
as a byproduct but you also have a lot of other
great things as well those people that are just so
focused on weight loss choosing the wrong program
that actually makes them unhealthy especially
if they've been given the bad advice of lowering
your calories okay because this is this is what
they'll say right here every diet works as long
as you keep your calories low how many times
have you ever heard this very bad advice when
you restrict calories you slow the metabolism and
you also cut nutrients too if you get in a healthy
eating plan you increase your nutrients and you
change your fuel to the right type of fuel and you
lose weight in a healthy way and you look better
next one on the bad advice six small meals per day
to prevent overeating okay which is the
worst advice because every time you eat
you trigger insulin so fasting is number two
very very important intermittent fasting you
need to skip your breakfast now i used to be the
guy that would recommend consuming and breakfast
well i found out that was bad information so
i changed in my book you don't want to consume
breakfast simply because you want to increase
your time of fasting it's going to really help you
shift your metabolism into burning your own fat
and you're going to be extremely healthy if you
do that and so instead of lowering your calories
decrease the frequency of eating and this one
right here which is at the top of the list you
need to stop snacking why because every time you
snack you stimulate insulin so these two can be
pretty much combined but i wanted to separate them
all right exercise well no that's a good thing
it's really good but that would probably be
down here number six as far as a health tip all
right reduce your added sugars now this is always
interesting they tell you to reduce your added
sugars to like six teaspoons of sugar per day
well that's still going to be way too high to
get into ketosis because you're still going to
increase insulin so why don't they just tell you
to get rid of all the sugars so again it's it's
advice but it's not the best advice in the world
all right eat your breakfast we already discussed
that how about this one there is no bad foods you
just have to eat variety foods foods will give you
fuel this right here is probably created
by the food the junk food industry
it is very bad advice because there are bad foods
okay there are junk foods that will give you some
temporary fuel but it's going to jack your insulin
and create all sorts of problems so there is
zero benefit in consuming certain foods and that
relates to this next one a little bit everything
in moderation in order to get into ketosis to
get your body to burn the right fuel which is fat
you have to bring the insulin down to do
that you have to bring your carbs down
on the low end okay so if everything's
in moderation you'll never get there
you want low carb moderate protein so we can do
moderate protein but higher amounts of fat okay
that's the ratios that you need not everything
in moderation so they're basically allowing you
to have everything in moderation junk food sugar
alcohol and you never really get anywhere with
your health in order to get healthy you can't have
certain things in moderation you must have them
very very low all right next one is no one diet is
for everyone each person is different what works
for some people might not work for someone else
and so that leaves you in a confused state where
you're trying diet after diet after diet you keep
trying to one day maybe you'll find the right diet
well i disagree with this one right here because
our bodies are very similar in certain things
especially our hormones especially insulin
any diet that helps you lower insulin
will help you any diet that helps you lower
insulin will increase your health the diets
that lower it more are going to produce more
benefit those diets that raise insulin are not
good diets and so if you understand the back end
of how fats burn and what hormones do what then
you can actually predict what diet is going to be
good or bad okay so we already talked about this
we talked about that so number four when you
do a keto plan which is low carb you want to
do it healthfully and what i mean by that is
you want to increase two things the quality of
your ingredients you want to do organic well
caught grass fed you also want to consume
foods that are high in nutrients that satisfy your
nutrient requirement and so by doing both of those
that is called healthy okay so healthy keto and
keto is about getting your body to burn ketones
which is the byproduct of fat so this is
number four very good advice and number five
and number five we can include the exercise
and sleep for all sorts of benefits as well as
reducing your stress okay so that would be number
five and so when i really looked at everything
these are the top five i couldn't think of
anything that was higher in the list if you
could think of something that's better than these
five please put them in the comments section below
before you go if you have a question about a
product or you're new to keto and you want to
know how to begin keto or you're on keto and you
need a debug because it's not going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to help
you this is just for the people in the us
hopefully in the future we'll be able to answer
everyone's call but i put the number down below
so you can call and get some help